[Music]
on this sunday night
home by eight the streets in quebec
falls silent as a curfew takes effect
quebec will likely see a drop in rates
but you know there are going to be
consequences
is it the answer to kerbin coveted 19
cases as ontario
considers the move more republicans turn
on u.s
president donald trump you don't deserve
to leave the party anymore
as lawmakers grow fearful of what
loyalists could do next
and selling off or selling out
are artists jeopardizing their legacies
by giving up the rights to their songs
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
colleen christie good evening thanks for
joining us we begin tonight in quebec
which is under a curfew for the first
time in more than half a century
the month-long restrictions started last
night from 8 o'clock to five this
morning the streets were mostly quiet
across the province
there were some protests and some
concerns that police were being too
heavy-handed
michael couture has our top story
tonight we weren't stopping we didn't
stop at any stores
melissa calhoun and her family were on
their way back to montreal from new
brunswick after attending to her ailing
father
she had hoped to return before the
provincial curfew came into effect
but was delayed at around 10 30 p.m
with three young kids in the back seat
quebec provincial police
pulled her car over basically they said
it appears as though you're in a gray
zone
which means you probably shouldn't be
getting the ticket
but because you're past curfew we have
no choice but to give you the ticket
both calhoun and her husband were each
fined over
fifteen hundred dollars the couple is
going to contest the penalty
and they could have a good case but the
people who protested saturday night
might have a tougher time
[Music]
dozens defied the curfew in montreal
marching through the streets claiming
it's an overreach by the government i
think it's
unjust and it's against the canadian
charter of rights and freedoms police
handed out dozens of fines across the
province at
similar demonstrations many protesters
vowed to fight the fines claiming the
curfew
is a violation of charter rights i think
the end
result will be that the emergency was
serious enough
that the measures were proportionate and
not excessive to the point of destroying
people
now the goal is to slow the spread of
covid19 curfews in countries like france
reduce the acceleration of transmission
for people who were 60 and older but
studies found
only a full lockdown worked for younger
age groups
this is a very you know sledgehammer
measure to try to
get things down and get mobility down at
the end of the day it may work slightly
but again there may be difficult
uh difficult discussions in terms of the
downstream consequences of this
despite the sledgehammer approach at
night quebec schools are set to restart
in-person learning
monday morning that has teacher unions
worried where are the new measures for
schools to keep
our kids safe to keep school staff
safe they're just not there some worry
without a full lockdown of the province
coveted 19 case numbers
will continue to climb mike lacrouter
global news ottawa
there are calls for ontario to follow
quebec's lead and impose a curfew in
that province
numbers are soaring a new modeling this
week is expected to have grim
predictions but as catherine ward
reports some experts believe a curfew
could make matters worse
but the other big thing about curfews is
that it's kind of
akin to squeezing that last drop of
juice out of an already squeezed lemon
restrictions hard limits and closures
and still the number of kovid 19 cases
in ontario
continues to climb before the holidays
we were begging people
to stay at home but half of the people
didn't listen so
i don't know what you do i think the
next step is is really
increased enforcement which isn't
something we don't want
marcus micalucci knows what it's like to
be under lockdown
the musician and teacher is living in
the uk and has had to adapt
i think that if people had done
what we needed to do more in the
beginning and just listened to it and
stayed locked down
you know kept away then we'd probably be
out of it sooner
sources tell global news ontario's
government is looking at the possibility
of imposing a curfew limiting
overnight movement however some experts
say that tactic
might not help as long as you restrict
and restrict and restrict people more
does it make them more adherent or does
it just give them more
incentive to find loopholes and have
their fatigue take out it the thing is i
don't think this is going to make much
of a difference
ironically it could potentially make
things worse because it's
driving people inside more and that's
where we're seeing a bulk of
transmission is occurring
infectious disease physicians also say a
curfew does not necessarily target the
root cause of the viruses spread
and some say more focus should be placed
on testing blitzes
implementing paid sick leave and the use
of isolation centers
people who are in essential workplaces
like factories food processing plants
warehouses if you get in the vac if
you're getting the virus
there it's it's something that a
lockdown doesn't address and you really
need to kind of look at those
to address it catherine ward global news
toronto more than a dozen people took
part in a rally today to draw attention
to ontario's
long-term care crisis
the demonstration happened outside saint
george community care
the for-profit facility has one of the
worst long-term care covered 19
outbreaks in ontario
right now it has more than 70 active
cases ndp leader jagmeet singh attended
the rally along with green party leader
anime paul her father was a resident at
the facility
he died in may after developing a
serious infection
no one in this country at any stage of
life should have to die
from a preventable bladder infection
that can be treated with a course of
antibiotics
that is what happened to my father okay
so he did not die from the virus but he
died from covid
according to toronto's university health
network which is temporarily managing
the home
17 residents have died in the latest
outbreak
14 from covid the arrival of two new
variants of covet 19 in canada
is putting renewed pressure on
governments to ramp up the vaccine
rollout
the first case of the south african
variant was detected late last week in
alberta
and as heather urex west explains
experts say it's only a matter of time
before we see more
as officials across canada work to
vaccinate as many people as they can
against covet 19
there are new reminders that the virus
is moving quickly too
there is a race here there's a race
between us getting this out of
circulation
and uh and it evolving in order to uh to
avoid the things that we're trying to do
to limit its growth
canada has detected its first case of
the south african variant of covid19
at least 14 cases of the uk variant have
been found here
as well they're no more deadly and the
vaccine will likely still
offer good protection but both variants
spread more easily in the community and
that
is a major cause for concern if you have
a more transmissible virus
even if it doesn't in and of itself
cause more severe disease
if you have more people infected with
the virus that's just a greater
proportion of people
infected which means a greater number of
hospitalizations and sadly a greater
number of deaths
what public health officials don't want
are these variants to begin
circulating widely a virus that behaves
differently
may not be as easily controlled with
current mask policies or capacity limits
and additional measures may be required
to keep infection levels at bay
it's entirely plausible that a dominant
contagious strain would mean that we
couldn't have schools open that's
that's possible my biggest concern
though is shared air honestly
that that even with masks on shared air
may become a little bit less safe
it's why the federal government has
taken new steps to keep these variants
from arriving in the country
requiring travelers now present a
negative covet test
before boarding an incoming flight we
have to make sure that
these variants that might spread more
easily do not
start rapid outbreaks in the community
and infecting large numbers of people
alberta's chief medical health officer
says there is no evidence the province's
first case of the south african variant
has spread in the community heather urex
west global news
calgary members of the u.s house of
representatives will introduce an
article of impeachment against
president donald trump this week and
some prominent republicans are joining
the call for trump to leave
office over his incitement of a violent
mob that stormed the capitol building
now as jennifer johnson reports
politicians on both sides of the aisle
are facing threats against their lives
from emboldened trump loyalists
more than 200 house members and over 37
senators are now calling on u.s
president donald trump to resign
be removed from office or face
impeachment top republicans joining that
list
i think the best way for our country
chuck is for the president to resign
and go away as soon as possible even the
president's former acting chief of staff
and one of his greatest offenders has
had enough
the ideas of the republican party are
bigger than one man
but i think if you have any role at all
in what happened on wednesday
that you sort of you don't deserve to
leave the party anymore a procession
carrying the body of capital police
officer brian sicknick
killed in the riots drove by the capitol
sunday afternoon
when the white house finally lowered its
flag to half-mast
the flag was lowered to the capitol
friday the president remains out of
sight as many lawmakers fear what his
loyalists may do next
the number of death threats that have
been thrown out against people like me
and frankly every member of congress
look at look at vice president pence one
of the most faithful guys to donald
trump
is now public enemy number one in trump
world several sources inside the white
house say president trump hasn't spoken
to pence since the siege
meanwhile house speaker nancy pelosi is
requesting members return to washington
an article of impeachment against the
president is expected to be introduced
late monday or tuesday
but some want to delay a possible senate
trial let's give
president elect biden the hundred days
he needs
to get his agenda off and running and
maybe
we'll send the articles sometimes after
that
to protect lawmakers and others twitter
has silenced the president
apple and amazon have crackdown on
another site favored by extremist parlor
washington is under a state of emergency
its mayor has asked the department of
homeland security
for added protection starting monday
as the national guard erects what it
says is a non-scalable fence protecting
the capitol
ahead of inauguration day jennifer
johnson global news
washington search crews off indonesia's
coast have located the black boxes from
passenger jet that crashed into the java
sea this weekend
officials detected pings from the flight
data recorder and the cockpit
voice recorder within 200 meters of the
crash site
efforts are underway to recover them
from the sea floor
parts of the engine from the boeing
737-500 series jet have been pulled from
the water along with pieces of the
fuselage
other debris and human remains 50
passengers including 10 children
and 12 crew members were on board when
the plane went down shortly after taking
off from indonesia's capital jakarta
the cause of the crash is still under
investigation
coming up as uk coveted numbers climb so
too
does its massive vaccine roll out
and what the pope is now saying about
getting the vaccine
britain is preparing to ramp up its
covet 19 inoculation program
more than 600 000 notices are expected
to arrive on doorsteps and
inboxes across england this week asking
the elderly to make a vaccine
appointment
the uk is aiming to vaccinate about 15
million people by the middle of next
month
so far around 2 million doses have been
administered
the country's health secretary says
britain is on course to meet its target
over the last week we've vaccinated more
people than in the entirety of
december so we're accelerating the
rollout getting to over 200 000 people a
day is
significant progress and amongst those
who we need to reach
most amongst the uh the over 80s
we've now vaccinated around a third of
all of the over 80s
officials hope a speedy mass vaccination
rollout will help get britain back to
normal life soon
the country entered its third national
lockdown earlier this month
pope francis has confirmed he'll be
vaccinated the 84 year old is scheduled
to get the shot as early as next week
when the vatican starts its inoculation
program
the pontiff is vulnerable to the virus
first his age
and he had part of his lung removed
during an illness when he was a young
man
the pope is urging everyone to get the
shot to protect not only
their lives but others the spanish
government is sending out rescue convoys
to deliver vaccines to
areas cut off by snow from storm
philomena
along with those vaccines convoys will
also be carrying food supplies as some
places begin facing shortages
the move comes after central spain
including madrid was paralyzed by its
heaviest snowfall in
decades four people have died because of
the blizzard and forecasters warn more
dangerous conditions are ahead
as temperatures drop in the next week
just ahead how two students are getting
pandemic information to
indigenous peoples here and around the
world
you're watching global national
as shots begin to reach remote first
nations across canada
indigenous leaders are encouraging their
communities to get vaccinated
as of friday indigenous services canada
had confirmed nearly 10
000 cases of covet 19 in first nations
communities across the country
but chiefs say some members are hesitant
to get the shot because of
discrimination
and distrust in the health care system
and that's not the only barrier facing
indigenous communities fighting the
virus
there's often a lack of information for
those who speak different languages
but as linda ailsworth reports a bc
medical student is helping to change
that
there's been a lot of information to
take in since the start of the kovit 19
pandemic
and a lot of changes to adapt to one of
the main things that people have had to
adapt to is
mass the second thing has to be about
social distancing
and the last thing about hand hygiene
but what if you were an indigenous
person who wasn't privy to that
information
because it wasn't available in your
native language a lot of the times
marginalized populations are left behind
and i think kobe 19 is a perfect example
to exemplify that
where indigenous communities across the
world are disproportionately being
affected by kova 19.
suk meets satchel a second year
university of bc medical student wasn't
the only one who was concerned
so was victor carmen a harvard student
on the other side of the continent
as an indigenous medical student i
felt like i was in a position where i
could do some good
it was on facebook that the two found
each other in combined forces
with a few other like-minded students to
make a difference
so one of the things we came up with was
translations for our nations where
we provide information about kobe 19
in indigenous languages they went about
recruiting over a hundred indigenous
speaking people in 40 countries to
translate fact sheets
then created a website that made it all
available free of charge
when we go to translations these are all
the different
indigenous languages that we have among
the many languages they've translated
samburu in northern kenya one of them
for kobe 19 information for indigenous
children and youth
and something like this which is very
visual the team was thrilled to get this
photo of the semburu children looking at
the material for the first time
everyone there was so receptive and they
really appreciated the efforts that were
being taken
the project has been such a success that
victor and sukmeet hope to roll out
information on the kovid 19 vaccine next
and perhaps even meet one day we talk
all the time about what we can do
together
to really make a difference in this
world linda ailsworth global news
up next what a major business deal will
mean for the legacy of one of canada's
iconic
musicians
to another music legend now they're some
of the best loved songs in this country
and around the world and
soon you may be hearing them on
commercials pitching everything from
cars to insurance neil young has sold
a half stake in his songs to an
investment company
that specializes in combining popular
music with advertising
as ross lord reports it's left his fans
wondering
what these massive business deals will
mean for youngs and
other artists legacies
[Music]
as a legendary singer-songwriter neil
young has a reputation
for protecting how his music is used
[Music]
but young songs will be connected to
commercial products
according to fellow canadian merck
mercuratis
he owns an investment company hypnosis
that just bought a 50
stake in young's catalog that's more
than 1 000 songs so we're able to put
more time and effort
into putting the songs in movies tv
commercials
making sure that they're on all the
right playlists on spotify and apple
mercuratis says he's been a neil young
fan since he was a child he says young
is at a point in his life where he's
wondering what will become of the songs
after he's gone
using songs to sell other products isn't
new
remember this bank of montreal
commercial from 1996
[Music]
to this day there's outrage that bob
dylan allowed a classic protest song to
be used in a bank promotion
i think we should fight against this
like like the times they are changing
these are counter culture songs against
the man
commercial songs are the man like it's
time
they are a change last month dylan sold
publishing rights to his entire catalog
more than 600 songs for between 300
million and 500 million dollars
stevie nicks of fleetwood mac fame
recently sold her music
for a reported 100 million dollars
young's deal
includes more than a thousand songs
reportedly for 150 million
although he keeps 50 ownership my job is
to bring neil
the best opportunities possible but the
the decisions will be ultimately being
made by neil as to whether or not
something is
is you know is done with the song on the
receiving end of those decisions
are fans like this former music reviewer
so if you suddenly hear a song that
helped define
you and your personality and how you've
lived and suddenly
it's selling motor oil
might be good if you're a car fan but if
you're not a car fan and you might be a
little bit offended he says it's unclear
if
song sell-offs are good for fans or if
the only winners are the artists and
businesses making the transactions
ross lord global news
that is global national for this sunday
i'm colleen christie
tonight's your canada is gimli manitoba
show us your part of the country
email your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching donna friesen will
be back at the desk tomorrow
have a good night
you